bon
jo
bonjour
jérémy demain j'ai 30
et je
vie absolument fabuleuse j'étais je fais
un métier qui me passionne
en fait plusieurs métiers qui me
passionne je gagne très bien ma vie j'ai
une relation avec ma blonde qui est de
plus en plus saine
au fur et à mesure des mois et des
années j'ai une maison que je qualifie
d' havre de paix j'ai des relations avec
des amis qui sont de plus en plus
authentique
au fur et à mesure que je grandis je
prends plus de deux mois de vacances par
année
j'ai une vie que je qualifie absolument
fabuleuse puis pourquoi je vous dis ça
aujourd'hui parce que ça n'a pas
toujours été le cas à présent les huit
ans mon père est décédé
comme je vous vois en ce moment
aujourd'hui j'ai mon père monte à cheval
son coeur s'est arrêté
il est mort puisque est beau la danse
des cas il est mort avant ce qu'il
aimait le plus au monde
ça c'est bon c'est un peu comme si
donald jong il mourrait en twittant une
insulte ça très beau c'est beau ça
serait magnifique
voilà j'ai grandi dans une famille
extrêmement aimanté vert à 19 20 ans
j'ai appris que j'ai compris que je vais
devenir humoriste je suis arrivé ici à
montréal à l'âge de 22 ans
et pour plein de raisons ça a été
extrêmement difficile de m'intégrer à ce
milieu d'eux
l'humour là ça a été difficile de percer
ça a été difficile d'apprendre à faire
mon métier il ya beaucoup beaucoup de
gens qui m'ont qui m'ont tourné le dos
et longtemps longtemps j'ai douté
longtemps j'ai pleuré j'ai j'ai voulu
tout abandonner et un jour en 2009
j'ai fait ce qu'on appelle une
dépression laissa une des définitions de
la dépression c'est ne pas accepter ce
qui est et j'avais beaucoup de mal à
accepter ce qui était ma santé était
vraiment pas du tout bonnes relations
avec ma blonde était absolument malsaine
j'étais loin de ma famille mes amis
j'avais une carrière au point mort au
point zéro qui ne l'est absolument nulle
part j'avais du mal à obtenir un visa
et par dessus tout j'avais cette douleur
inexprimée d'un père que j'avais vu
mourir plusieurs années auparavant
et quand tu fais une dépression en
général selon iwata deux choix soit tu
commences à prendre des antidépresseurs
et tu tombes dans un espèce de cercle
vicieux chimiques qui fait jusqu'à chez
le problème finalement c'est comme tu
prends des anti-dépresseurs c'est un peu
comme quand maman d'un enfant va ranger
ta chambre
euh de la rangée il met tous les jouets
sous son lit il dit j'ai rangé ma
chambre n'ont pas couvert le problème tu
l'as pas résolu ça va comme ça que je
vois et d'antidépresseurs et d'ailleurs
je me suis renseigné à plusieurs
personnes
leurs spécialistes qui m'ont dit que
seulement 10 % des gens ont vraiment
besoin d'anti dépresseurs les autres 90
% donc les gens dans mon cas moi peuvent
s'en sortir sans et oui ça va être
beaucoup plus long est beaucoup plus
périlleux mais il ya une façon de le
faire et c'est ça que j'ai choisi de
faire quand j'ai ma dépression et comme
je vous dis une dépression des fois ma
blonde arrivée à la maison elle me
retrouvais habillé dans son lit mes
chaussures au pied n'a même pas le
courage de remettre et chaussures se
sent pas bien en général
ou alors tu as une trop grosse bedaine
vite arrive pas de baisser mais ça ça
m'a problème ça mais voilà j'ai décidé
j'ai décidé de renaître
j'ai demandé à la vie j'ai dit donne moi
tout ce que tu peux montre moi tout ce
que je peux faire pour aller vers un
meilleur et j'ai tout essayé tout ce que
je pouvais essayer j'ai lu des dizaines
de livres
j'ai suivi des thérapies jardin des
centaines de conférences j'ai fait de
l'homéopathie effets de l'acupuncture
effet de l'immunothérapie
j'ai fait tout ce que je pouvais faire
tout ce que l'on donnait jallet
bert versa et plus je faisais ça plus je
découvrais différents outils plus ma vie
s'améliorer plus changé intérieurement
plus ma vie extérieure devenait facile
et j'ai continué à faire ça pendant
plusieurs années il n'y a pas longtemps
l'organisation ted m'a contacté et il
demande et vient parler tu as juste vrai
15 minutes jeudi 15 minutes il faut que
je parle d'une chose c'est quoi la chose
la plus importante
selon moi qui m'a aidé le plus est la
réponse de ça se trouve dans la question
c'est quoi le bonheur
vous savez c'est cette question que tout
le monde se pose depuis photo depuis des
dernières années c'est devenu un
classique presque clichés c'est quoi le
bonheur et chaque personne a sa
définition du bonheur
moi je vous dire ma définition à moins
de bonheur c'est être bien avec soi
c'est en paix c'est au calme c'est ça
que je pense le bonheur c'est un état de
calme constant et la question c'est
comment on arrive là c'est une très
bonne question que vous posez merci de
la pause et chaque être humain ressemble
à sa merci pour mes talents de graphiste
chaque être humain selon moi ressemble à
ça c'est quoi
les croix cd programmation qu'on a qu'on
combat qu'on a pris dans la nuit souvent
entre 0 et 7 ans toutes ces choses là
sont des choses qui sont ancrés en nous
qui sont enracinés en nous depuis qu'on
est tout petit presque toutes des choses
qu'on a vécu ses concepteurs ce qu'ont
appris de nos parents c'est peut-être
des traumatismes des peurs des deuils
des hontes des abandons un père qui t'a
battu un maire quitte à violer peu
importe ce que c'est on a tous vécu nos
choses et on a tous eu des choses ancré
en nous qu'ils sont arrivés comme jeudi
entre 0 et 7 ans ce qui fait que quand
on grandit dans la vie et qu'il arrive
différentes sortes de situations on
réagit pas en fonction de la situation
on réagit en fonction de notre passé une
programmation un mental et donc l'idée
de ça l'idée de bonheur d'être en paix
c'est d'arriver et éventuellement à sa
de tendre vers ça arrive un qui fait la
gueule il y en a un qui sourit parce
qu'il est beaucoup plus d'heureux battu
allemand et et la question c'est comment
c'est comme en arriver là et c'est une
c'est une très bonne question parce que
voyez moi ce que je pense dans la vie
j'ai lu une phrase un jour que je
trouvais merveilleuse c'est dans la vie
on n'attire pas ce qu'on veut dans la
vie
on attire ce qu'on est et je le répète
c'est important on n'attire pas ce qu'on
veut
on attire ce qu'on est vous savez
souvent on est on est comme une espèce
de on est tous une sorte de boule
d'énergie on vit tous de l'énergie aie
cnrj là est composé de deux choses ce
qu'on pense le conscient et ce qu'on
ressent l'inconscient donc les
programmations qu'on s'est mis dans
votre dans notre corps est souvent c'est
l'inconscient qui gagne donc si mettons
dans la vie tu te dis moi je veux de
l'argent 1 le célèbre demandez vous
recevrez moi je veux de l'argent je veux
devenir millionnaire est ce que tu
penses consciemment mais que
inconsciemment ce que tu te dis c'est
l'argent a séparé mes parents l'argent
fait cas des pays qui sont en guerre
depuis des années l'argent fait que des
politiciens de vienne vers eux et font
tout pour absolument gagner cet argent
là donc une mauvaise image de l'argent
inconsciemment c'est que votre énergie
vibre entre ces deux choses là et
souvent c'est l'inconscient qui prend le
dessus sur le conscient donc toute votre
vie vous avez passé à avoir du mal à
surtout dans la pénurie avoir un peu
d'argent plus d'argent un peu d'argent
plus d'argent et vous n'avez jamais
capable de vous en sortir
simplement parce que vous avez une
programmation en vous qui ressemble à ça
donc la question c'est comment comment
tendre décroît a pu croire comme
entendre d'une vie agitée d'une vie
souffrante à une vie plus simple plus
libre moi j'ai découvert quatre moyens
il en existe beaucoup d'autres mais ces
moyens que personnellement j'ai j'ai
expérimenté le premier qui m'a beaucoup
aidé c'est le yoga ces passionnés qui
font du yoga
escada qui font du yoga oui la
définition du yoga vous la connaissez
sûrement c'est unir le corps et l'esprit
pour qu'ils ne fassent plus qu'un mois
j'ai essayé le yoga
ma définition à moi s'est imposé à ton
corps des positions improbables que ton
esprit a pas du tout envie de faire dans
la vie écouter les positions et agacé
n'importe quoi là des fois je suis chez
moi je suis les positions même mon chat
regardez qu'avec corps lui même moi je
serai pas ça non non non et il se lèche
le cul qu'on pensait on est cgc yoga et
c'est absolument merveilleux je vous le
recommande c'est vraiment ça nous permet
d'être complètement présent à ce qu'on
fait de ressentir notre corps d'ailleurs
c'est là qu'ils se mettent au yoga ce
que j'ai fait dernièrement j'en fais le
soir avant de me coucher tu dors
beaucoup plus sereinement et calmement
deuxième outil qui m'a beaucoup aidé à
déraciner mai mais programmation c'est
la méditation lever la main les gens qui
médite je parle de mutation sur
quelqu'un ok donc six personnes enfin
levé la main les gens qui se lave
j'espère que tout n'a pas levé la main
tout le monde cela la gazon je vous pose
c'est pourquoi vous l'avez vous allez me
dire pour enlever les impuretés pour
enlever les saletés de mon corps est
souvent aussi pour te relaxer parce que
de l'eau chaude ça détend c'est
exactement pour ça qu'on m'ait dite
c'est exactement pour ça qu'on me dit
y'a pas longtemps je suis allé faire un
jeu fait dans un centre de méditation à
montebello qui s'appelle vipassana et là
bas il nous enseigne une sorte de
méditation qui fait que justement un on
enlève les impuretés les programmations
de notre corps vraiment en méditant
littéralement et 2 on apprend à
maîtriser son esprit parce que c'est ça
le plus gros mots du 21e siècle et je
cite une phrase mais je sais plus de qui
c'est qui disait que le plus gros mots
de ce siècle là c'est que les gens sont
pas capables de rester seul avec
eux-mêmes rien faire paca pas quand
jérôme anthony capable de rester salarié
intérêts ouais je suis chez moi je tout
seul et si tu fais un joli regard d'une
série j'appelle mes amis j'écoute de la
musique et cei et c'est l'état soir 5
minutes 10 minutes ferme les yeux
restent avec toi la majorité des gens
sont incapables
après cinq milieux ton esprit va te dire
ok c'est autre chose va envoyer un mail
va regarder une série
appelle tes amies ça on est pas capable
on a surtout besoin qu'on a l'impression
faire des choses pour remplir notre vie
et apprendre à maîtriser son esprit
apprendre à devenir maître de son esprit
elle est là la clé parce que la plupart
des gens on est esclave de notre esprit
on subit ce que notre esprit nous dit de
faire a ça devrait être l'inversé
selon avec voilà la méditation a été
quelque chose pour moi et bien je
pratique régulièrement cette mutation là
elle me cale elle m'apaise ils ont
demandé à 1 m steeple hmida vous
connaissez sûrement
qu'est-ce que qui demandait qu'est ce
que la méditation t'a apporté puis il a
dit rien par contre ça m'a enlevé le
stress en enlever la peur de mourir ça
n'enlevait l'anxiété
ça m'a enlevé la peur du futur tout des
choses auxquelles je pense qu'on a tous
un peu peuvent pas qu'ils ont tous un
petit peu concernés
je vous recommande vivement la la
méditation troisième outil qui m'a
beaucoup aidé c'est la communication non
violente et ça c'est un outil qui met
dans ce moment dans ma vie
d'ailleurs il ya un livre extraordinaire
là dessus qui s'appelle la communication
non violente de marque rosenberg que je
vous recommande
et en gros pour vulgariser sur son
enseignement c'est qui nous apprend à
nous connecter avec nous mêmes à nos
proches
les émotions voyez moi j'ai grandi dans
une famille aimante mais avec des gens
qui avaient jamais appris à exprimer
leurs émotions
donc si jamais vraiment dit les choses
et beaucoup de non dits et depuis
dernièrement j'apprends à communiquer
avec mes émotions et j'aurai moi dans ma
tête il y avait cinq émotion dans la
tête au départ du jeune appris avec
tristesse la colère la joie parle pas il
n'a plus de 80 des émotions mg et en
voyant ça que j'ai appris à connecter
avec moi et ce qu'il apprend en fait
marc rotenberg qui nous apprend c'est
que bien chaque émotion se cache un
besoin non satisfait chaque émotion
il ya un besoin non satisfait comme par
exemple n'y a pas encore un ami qui est
venu voir que m'a dit je suis jalouse je
suis jalouse parce que je vois mon
copain car ai pas parlé avec deux filles
ça me rend jalouse là je me suis dit ok
derrière chaque émotion il ya un besoin
je me suis je vais essayer de trouver
son besoin elle puisque tard ait besoin
d'être rassuré est ce que c'est une
chaîne venait de voir exe mon amour tu
es la seule que j'aime je vais pas
couché avec d'autres filles je t'aime
moi non sans tirer dessus une mille feux
elle m'a dit oui avec des accès jalousie
il y avait un besoin d'être rassurés a
pas seulement le besoin est satisfait
l'émotion négative disparaît c'est aussi
simple que ça donc je vous encourage
vraiment à connecter avec vous même et
surtout à lire ce niveau 4e outils selon
l'outil qui m'a le plus aidé durant les
dernières années c'est l'hypnose est
lâché quand je parle dit nous en ferons
au waou l'hypnose comme meissner au
compte de 3 tu deviens un cochon d'inde
puis tu chantes du eminem en égrenant
c'est pas ça c'est pas ça ça c'est le
côté spectacle le vrai côté de l'hypnose
c'est il peut voir un signe d'ailleurs
par rapport à l'hypnose ces
scientifiques
scientifiquement il ya beaucoup à 8,5
risques ça a aidé des milliers et des
milliers de gens je veux dire il ya des
femmes qui accouchent sous hypnose mon
oncle qui a fumé pendant 20 ans deux
paquets de cigarettes par jour à arrêter
de fumer grâce à l'hypnose savez
l'hypnose pour vulgariser un peu c'est
comme si notre notre corps notre cerveau
notre inconscient était comme un disque
dur d'ordinateur et l'hypnose un
antivirus parce que je vous dis que vous
savez sûrement le corps a des pouvoir
d'auto guérison quand vous coupez trois
quatre jours plus tard ça cicatrise
c'est pareil par rapport à ses blessures
la le corps a des pouvoir d'auto des
rires ça sauf que ça prend des moyens
comme l'hypnose est selon moi l'hypnose
est un des moyens les plus
fort surtout les plus rapides d'aller
déterrer tout ça voilà
mais on va lancer ça que je vais
encourager les gens à faire c'est se
guérir
je me suis rendu compte que plus je ne
guérissait intérieur plus j'enlevais
chaque croix et plus ma vie devenait
simple c'est un peu comme ça que je vois
les choses
vous savez moi j'ai j'ai longtemps
forcés dans la vie j'entends pensé qu'il
fallait forcer pour avoir plus d'argent
pour avoir plus de célébrités dans mon
cas plus de fans facebook pour courir
après les projets après les gens et puis
le jour où j'ai compris qu'on attire ce
qu'on est
j'ai réalisé que plus jeune nettoyer et
plus les choses vont arriver librement
et puis dans ma vie et je l'expérimenté
en ce moment j'ai pu a forcé je ne force
plus quand je voudrais que ma vie est
fabuleuse elle est fabuleuse mais elle
est simple mais à peine avant je voulais
courir un sprint aujourd'hui je suis sur
place mais les choses arrivent tout seul
simplement parce que j'ai retiré ou en
tout cas une partie de ces choses là je
pense que la vie c'est un peu comme
c'est un peu comme une rivière final
c'est bizarre comme analogie mais je
pense qu'on est tous comme une rivière
et que tous ces problèmes là toutes ses
programmations mental là qu'on a pris
dans notre vie sont des rochers qui sont
mis en travers de la rivière l'événement
il ya tellement de rochers ça fait un
barrage et l'eau peut plus passer c'est
chloé c'est de forcer pour passer le
temps passé au dessus passer à côté on
veut forcer ce qu'on fait souvent mon
avis mais je me suis rendu compte qu'en
enlevant ça quand on le vend ses
blessures la commencer programmation lac
en déprogrammant j'enlevais une roche
une à une et l'eau coulait de plus en
plus simplement c'est que c'est ça que
je ne suggère à tous pour être heureux
c'est de nous guérir pour que la vie
puisse couler tout simplement merci
beaucoup
[Applaudissements]